So we've seen how to use recursive definitions to make
words, and to define concepts like ancestors. Now we're going
to see how to use recursive definitions to define a
procedure. And we're going to start with the procedure that we
already defined in unit two. We defined the factorial procedure.
And we defined factorial as the number of ways that
we can order n items, and the input is the
number n. And that could be calculated by multiplying n times
n minus 1 times n minus 2, and so on until we get down to the 1.
So that definition is not very precise mathematically,
and the problem with this as a mathematical definition.
Is, it's got this, dot dot dot in
it, and humans sort of understand that correctly, what
that dot dot dot means, but it's not a
very precise mathematical definition. If we use a recursive
definition, we can define factorial in a much more
precise way. And we need to do that by
giving a base case, so for the base case
we want to think about the simplest input, something where
we already know that answer. And for factorial, and
for many procedures that involved numbers, the simplest input
is the number 0. So if we try factorial
0, the number of ways to arrange 0 things is
defined as 1. So we know that result. That's going to be our base case.
Now all we need to do is define the recursive case, where we want to define what
the meaning of factorial for any number n is. Where n is any
integer greater than 0, and we can define that in terms of
the factorial of the smaller numbers. So if you look at this definition
with the dot dot dot, well we see that the factorial of n is
n times n minus 1 and so forth. Well, this what we have here, is actually the
factorial of n minus 1. So that means that we can define the factorial then as
n times the factorial of n minus 1.
And that's our recursive case, and this definition matches
our intuition well, if we think about factorial
meaning the number of ways to arrange n objects.
This corresponds exactly the way we think about this, that
we have n ways to pick the first item. And once
we've picked the first item, well, we have n items left,
and factorial of n minus 1, gives us the number of
ways to arrange the remaining n minus 1 items. So
that's a way to define this mathematically. So now, I'll leave
it to you as a quiz, to figure out how to
define a procedure, that computes factorial without using a while loop.